that's going to change they indicate right and you talked about the fact of them having us having eight guys in double figures and right now while you have the opportunity we want to congratulate Alvin Gentry on his 500th career win yes so 500 for a good guy and they get closer at the agency to the Western complex that's all Alvin cares about right now he's moving up in the standings and they're the Jersey exchange 1 & 2 Zion Williamson Java ran two guys are gonna be linked for trapper right great scene and as I said at the top of the telecast tonight nice for a change it was ours we got to do the telecast network didn't steal it one against two